retired senate majority leader harry
reid has died at 82 after a fight with
pancreatic cancer for more than three
decades a nevada democrat was known as
one of the toughest deal makers in
congress during a time of immense
partisan divisions in a statement
president biden who served in the senate
with reid for 22 years said for harry it
wasn't about power for power's sake it
was about the power to do right for the
people
chief washington correspondent major
garrett has more on the legacy of the
longtime democratic leader
i didn't make it
in life because my athletic prowess
i didn't make it because of my good
looks
i didn't make it because i'm a genius
i made it because i worked hard those
words spoken to be the key to success by
a man who embodied what hard work and
tenacity truly means harry reid earned a
reputation as one of the toughest
lawmakers in congress the deal doesn't
have to be a fight
there's a simple path forward just put
all four bills together bring him the
floor a former amateur boxer he brought
a willingness to draw partisan blood and
famously carried the motto i would
rather dance than fight but i know how
to fight recoverings were willing to do
anything to take health care away from
millions of people
scores of votes to repeal it what a
waste of the taxpayers time reid grew up
in the small town of searchlight nevada
in a cabin with no indoor plumbing he
had to hitchhike 40 miles to attend high
school where he met his wife landry
gould she's been the being of my
existence
in my personal life and my public life
reed was elected to the house in 1982
rising to the heights of power serving
as senate majority leader in 2007
over his 34-year congressional career
read was behind many landmark democratic
victories pushing through a sweeping
economic stimulus after the great
recession and reed played a significant
role in passing the affordable care act
which he later described as his favorite
but hardest fight in the senate i want
people to stay nevada to know that i am
so grateful and i have done my best i
haven't been perfect but i've really
tried my hardest
garage joins us now along with cbs news
political contributor joel payne a
democratic party strategist who worked
for senator reid good morning to you
both major let's begin with you what do
you think his legacy will be
so let's start in nevada no one raises
rises to national prominence without
getting re-elected so in nevada harry
reid's legacy is environmental first and
foremost he kept something from
happening that was going to happen
making yucca mountain the final resting
place for all nuclear waste in this
country harry reid blocked that a
significant victory for nevada he also
brought the nevada presidential caucuses
to that state in 2008 and ever since
it's been third in line in the
democratic nominating process elevating
nevada's importance
also he built the most important
political machine in the state history
for 20 years or more anyone who made a
political move in nevada democrat or
republican had to vector off harry reid
and his political machine nationally he
was mitch mcconnell before mitch
mcconnell what do i mean by that he was
a tenacious party and senate leader who
used all the procedural rules of that
body to get what he wanted to achieve
often to the consternation and boiling
fury of his political opposition he also
centralized power in leadership offices
in ways even lyndon johnson did not
lastly on a national level he
intensified what was already happening
an intense fight over the future of the
federal bench that legacy on the federal
bench and its implications for the
supreme court also part of harry reid's
legacy
joel speaking of
the current minority leader mitch
mcconnell he praised senator reid on
twitter yesterday saying even though
they had intense conflict he appreciated
the friendship having worked for him
what was that relationship really like
in the halls of congress and what stands
out to you about how he conducted
himself on the hill
well harry reid was an amateur boxer and
styles make fights and i guess you could
say reed mcconnell probably looked at
each other and saw similar fighters they
saw mirror images of each other people
who were you know for lack of a better
term gym rats who worked their way up
from the back bench of the senate all
the way up to leadership and just
understand how to get hard things done i
think that's the read legacy major
talked a little bit about
some of those accomplishments nationally
i worked for him at the beginning of the
obama administration in 2009 and 10. and
i'll tell you it was the most productive
congress in history you just go back and
look at those accomplishments the aca
but wall street reform the lilly
ledbetter fair pay act uh for for
fairness for women in the workplace uh
you know i mean the repeal of don't ask
don't tell
s chip 911 first responders bill it was
a modern day great society and harry
reid helped lord over it
major speaking of former president obama
he encouraged then senator obama to run
for president president obama said in
the statement last night i wouldn't have
been president had it not been for your
encouragement and support i wouldn't
have gotten i would wouldn't have got
most of what i'd got done without your
skill and determination
let's talk about that skill and
determination and some of the
legislation that was passed major
including the affordable care act was
that his greatest achievement
i don't think there's any question that
from a procedural point of view and from
moving a complex piece of legislation
through congress
the affordable care act is without
question harry reid's legacy
he believed that that bill would stand
the test of time not only politically
but practically and by all measures it
has more people are signing up yes it
requires subsidies but there is no
longer talk in republican circles as
there was vociferously for years about
repealing it and harry reid used every
tool in the book to deal with a 60-vote
senate majority of democrats remember
that to get democrats on board even
though they were reluctant and yes did
he hand out what were described at the
time probably accurately as special
favors in louisiana and nebraska to get
that 60-vote coalition yes he did but he
considered the goal worth all of the
hard work and
sometimes the uncomfortable deals
necessary to make that legislation not
only a reality but one that has stuck
and stayed in american political and
insurance life
indeed he will be long remembered uh
major garrett and joel payne always good
to see you both thank you very much